[musique]
elle
elle a une bonne audition chez chaque chien mais avec
son nadezhdin à partir sur le plan de poste est
bête là-bas la différence même s'il
aux bords de l'ennemi immédiatement sur le chemin qu'elle
dès que vous êtes un chien - messieurs
a augmenté de prix pour obéir au blâme pas
survécu plus de
il y aura des bombardements puis se précipite littéralement
viens dans la minute elle
libéré pour damner je suis déjà
compris maintenant je vais option
[musique]
sur
s'il te plaît, économisons sur le lit et
l'arrivée a été serrée par le chernukha lui-même était la sortie
franchise et couteaux à diriger et selon Albanov
téléphone chinois obtenir assez d'anapa
comme sédatif
[musique]
Avec